Hello and welcome to the final video in our series of exercise 1, in this we are going
to be tidying up the end, we are going to be testing and getting the whole thing to
work. To get back in the engine the first thing I would like you to do is to come into
our config file, GBC sitting down, and we need to set our behaviour once, we are going
to sell that to GBC sitting down, file and say. And the next thing I would like you to
do is to come into the chair, and we are going to sort out this collision, so we already
have the interface here, so I am going to implement these events and put the code, the first one
is the turn off collision, implement and this is the straightforward, we are going to grab
our chair mesh, drag out, and set collision enabled, log that in and we are ok with no
collision, so we are just turning off the collision at this point, next up I want to
do the turn on collision, and this is a little bit more complicated, because we don't want to turn
the collision on immediately, because the actor will still be over it, it would push them away
and it would look a bit unnatural, so what I am going to do is I am going to add in a check to
see that the actor is far enough away before turning the collision back on again, so the first
thing is this character, right hand click and promote to a variable, then I am going to drag off
and I am going to do set timeout by event, and so this I am going to set to 0.5
and then I am going to make it loop, so this means any event which is attached to here,
it is going to happen twice a second, whilst this timer is on,
now I am going to want to turn off this timer, so I am going to save it to a variable and call it timeout,
so I am going to drag off this event, go add custom event,
and I am going to call this check distance,
and from this I am going to drag in the actor, get to it, and I am going to get the actor location,
and also select the actor location and go ctrl D in order to duplicate it,
then I can drag off and get the distance in vector,
so this is going to return me a float of the distance between the actor and the chair,
now if this is greater than 120, then I want to turn the collision back on,
so hold down B to bring up a branch,
lock that up in and connect that up,
then what I can do is I can get the chair and set collision enabled,
if it is true, and I want to set this back to collision enabled,
then finally I want to get the timer, and I will be applause this,
applause timer by hand,
so that should give us power code in order to turn it back on, just come away until the actor is
far enough away and then switch the collision back on, now there's one more thing that I need to do
and that's to call this, so I'm going to go back into gameplay behavior,
and after the final play montage, I'm going to drag in the reference to the smart object,
and I'm going to set, I'm going to turn,
and then I'm going to set the collision on,
now in order to get this to work, I also need to plug in the avatar to the actor here,
so that gives it all of the information in needs,
okay let's test this out, in fact in the world now I'm going to press simulate,
and we seem to have a problem, our character is wondering about,
but he is not noticing the chair, I know why this problem is, if I had push down p I can see the
navigation, and the actor is only going to go and do the behavior, if it is able to reach the
slot, but because of the way we have set up this, the navigation cannot find a route to get
close enough to do the slot, but it's a relatively easy fix, just going to jump back into the chair,
and in the viewport, and going to take the smart object, and move it forward,
and that way it should be picked up, now this will affect how the animation is played,
but because of the way the animation is set up it should still work,
so now if I push play, you can see our character immediately walks over to the chair and sits down,
waits three seconds, and stands the cover again, and nearly sits down again,
so that looks like it's working, however what I would like to do is to make sure this is
completely working, I'm going to bring up three chairs, and I'm dragging with alt button held down,
and I'm going to bring up six ai, and then I'm going to press simulate,
now this looks like it is working, probably three of them have the claim to spot at only one time,
however they're having a bit of trouble because the other ai are getting in the way,
so let's see if we can do something about that,
the first thing that I'm going to do is I'm going to go into our npc chair finder,
and on the movement component, I'm going to search for rvo, and turn on use rvo avoidance,
and I'm going to go into the test, and see if there's still any problems,
slightly better, what rvo avoidance does is it means that the characters will give a slight
push away from each other, so it's harder for them to get stuck,
now there's one more thing I'd like to do, and this needs to be done on the BP chair,
and for that I'm going to add in a nav modifier,
and in the nav modifier, I'm going to change the area class to a obstacle,
and in order to get this to work, I'm going to add in a sphere collision,
I'm going to expand it out to be about
Haiti, I'm going to drag it out in front of the chair, maybe a little bigger,
and if we have a look at the environment, you can now see we have a little costly area around
the chairs, and if I was to run in this, you're going to see that they're not going to want to
get close to the chairs anymore, unless they have to, so they will move away from the chairs,
for doing anything, and they won't cross in front of it, they'll give it a bit of space,
and this really does sort of meet and eat all lock,
and allows the characters to have a more natural walking in,
and with that we come to the end of exercise one, and we will be doing a couple of other little
bits and bobs, but nothing is going to be as complicated as this, so thank you very much.